speculative evolution or speculative
biology can be defined as a genre
focused on hypothetical scenarios in the
evolution of life
today speculative evolution is
everywhere from video games to graphic
novels to any of the hundreds of amazing
online projects that explore worlds
beyond our own
but how did we get here
interest in the biology of fictional
life wasn't always so widespread
monsters from ancient myth weren't
typically thought of to be part of an
ecosystem they just kind of existed
the origin and rise of speculative
evolution as we know it today is a
fascinating tale deeply intertwined with
scientific advancement and full of
unexpected twists
so for this special entry into the
archive i'll give you the full tour of
this genre's incredible history and
reveal the evolution of speculative
evolution
let's start by winding back the clock to
1895.
it's been almost 40 years since charles
darwin published his theory of evolution
this foundational idea that all species
gradually change over time and through
the process of natural selection become
better suited to their environment and
by the turn of the century the
scientific community and the majority of
the educated public had accepted
evolution as a fact at this time in a
small town in the english countryside
science teacher turned author h.g wells
came up with an idea for a story called
the time machine the novel follows an
intrepid english inventor on his journey
into an imagined future the novel
represented a lot of firsts for science
fiction and has been adapted into
numerous films most famously in 1960 in
both the novel and the film upon
arriving into the distant future using
his titular time machine the protagonist
realizes that darwinian evolution has
changed the english countryside beyond
recognition not only is the world now
populated with strange plant life
unfamiliar to the time traveler but
humans have evolved as well having split
into a prey species the uncanny
childlike eloy and a predator species
the secretive subterranean morlocks the
1960 film portrays the morlocks as these
weird yeti-like things an effect that
hasn't aged particularly well but their
description in the novel is more ominous
with the narrator likening their
appearance to subterranean fish their
bodies slick and bleached from millennia
spent adapting to the caverns most of
the science in this section is now
somewhat outdated but the story doesn't
end here while this first section of the
novel is most popular and the only one
covered in film adaptations the truly
groundbreaking chapters come after
the time traveler then journeys millions
of years forward and encounters a barren
version of earth lit by a dying red sun
on a ruined shoreline the time traveler
sees that giant crab-like creatures have
evolved and now keep a grim vigil over
this dying land a sight that nearly
shatters his psyche pushing even further
into the future he witnesses the final
days of earth whereupon a blood-red sea
an indescribable mass of tentacles rises
from the water a visual so beyond his
19th century comprehension it causes his
mind to collapse
fitting for a novel about time travel
this section feels impossibly ahead of
its time it doesn't read like something
written over 30 years before the
invention of sliced bread
by speculating on what life might look
like millions of years beyond his own
time wells had inadvertently opened the
door to a whole new literary genre the
genre of speculative evolution
the people of mars probably walk on
their hind legs
their barrel chested bodies covered with
a coating of down their ample skulls
would be crammed with intelligence
and their trunk-like noses indispensable
for feats of engineering
the next great frontier in speculative
evolution would emerge that same year
when astronomer percival lowell produced
an account of what he believed to be
canals on the surface of mars what we
now know to be an optical illusion
caused by streaks of dust was at the
time believed by some to be evidence
that there was complex life on the next
rock over from earth
inspired by these findings h.g wells
would publish the war of the worlds just
two years after the time machine a novel
notable for popularizing the alien
invasion story
wells tale about martians invading earth
is widely interpreted as commentary on
british imperialism yet war of the
worlds could also be considered another
founding work of speculative evolution
before the book's release wells
published numerous articles speculating
about what life on mars might look like
discussing his theories for how plant
and animal life might evolve we now know
that mars can't support life for a range
of reasons but at the time this was
reasonable scientific conjecture it's
interesting to read these articles
because they really feel like someone
gushing about a speculative world
they've created and the early ideas for
the martians and their planet wells
outlines are almost unchanged in war of
the worlds which suggests this little
project inspired the massively
influential follow-up one of the most
important sci-fi novels ever began with
the author dreaming about speculative
ecosystems
today a space conscious public avidly
consumes tons of story material about
life on other planets
in the 20th century the war of the
worlds would inspire numerous other
invasion stories which tended to echo
public perceptions of threat bolstered
by reports of supposed ufos in a rising
public interest in everything space
related science fiction stories based on
threats from the stars became a common
form of entertainment yet with a few
exceptions these aliens weren't quite
speculative in the way wells early work
was they were more things that went bump
in the night what ecosystems or
evolutionary paths created these aliens
was rarely at the forefront of these
stories they were essentially fantasy
monsters with their speculative biology
and afterthought at best in the 1950s
especially the aliens of hollywood came
to represent fears of communist
infiltration with the paranoia that
agents of the enemy were everywhere
manifesting as literal aliens in
disguise
through the years there have been
frequent rumors that martians disguised
as earthmen walk amongst us
these stories are perhaps strengthened
by the thousands of reports of
unidentified flying objects passing in
an endless procession across our skies
while the initial speculative intrigue
that inspired wells to write war of the
worlds in the first place had largely
been forgotten by the midpoint of the
20th century some lesser-known
speculative projects did emerge during
this time in 1957 animation director
ward kimball got funding from walt
disney to create mars and beyond an
animated special most famous for
depicting what conditions on mars might
be like given sufficient water with
advice from astronomer dr e c silfer
kimball and his team brought to life an
impressively alien array of speculative
life forms like trilobite creatures that
can endure martian dust storms
fast-growing carnivorous plant life and
a slew of predators including one that
incapacitates prey with poisonous gas
and another that stuns with ultrasonic
waves
perhaps most notable of all one sequence
also speculates on life based on
entirely new chemical patterns imagining
organisms based on silicon instead of
carbon providing a range of surreal new
forms
while mars and beyond would be largely
forgotten over the following decades the
piece stands as remarkably innovative by
the standards of its time
throughout the same period running
parallel to the wave of aliens were
stories which followed in the footsteps
of the time machine and explored future
and alternate evolution on earth in 1930
author olaf stapleton released the novel
last and first men which chronicles a
speculative future of humanity across 2
billion years in 18 human species the
book is somewhat unwieldy but it did
anticipate the invention of genetic
engineering
the next major work that didn't involve
aliens came in 1961
with the account of naturalist harold
stumpke's expedition to an island chain
in the south pacific
the report describes in detail a
previously unknown order of mammals
known as the snouters these mammals are
distinguished by the nasarium a
structure derived from their nose that
has been adapted for all sorts of
purposes
reportedly some used their noses for
walking others for ensnaring prey and
still others for rudimentary flight if
all this sounds too fantastical to be
real that's because it was a total
fabrication harold stumpke wasn't a real
person but the pseudonym of the real
author gerald steiner a zoologist who
wrote and published his book on the
snouters to prank his colleagues yet the
snouters mark several important firsts
in the history of speculative evolution
containing a detailed taxonomic tree and
a surprising amount of thought put into
the niches each snouter fills in fact
the tone itself is so dry and scholarly
that it successfully mimics a scientific
work and has become something of a
favorite prank among zoologists with
several scientists and publishers having
written about the snowders since as if
they were real to keep the hoax alive
and when scientists actually discovered
a new species of rodent with a uniquely
large nose in 2015 they officially named
the animal sulawesi snouter in honor of
steiner's fictitious creatures
while the snouters project was limited
to a single island archipelago two
decades later in 1981 author dougal
dixon would forever change the genre
with his book after man set 50 million
years from now after man explored the
biology of speculative life-forms that
have evolved following a mass extinction
to this day after man is recognized as
the first truly large-scale speculative
evolution project involving an entire
world with a vast array of species
after man also marks the first time the
terms speculative evolution and
speculative biology were used in writing
to describe a work
some of my favorite creatures from this
project include the rabux which are
rabbits that have evolved to fill the
grazing niche of deer or the enormous
vortex filter feeders evolved from
penguins that fill the role left behind
by whales perhaps the most famous
creature from after man is the night
stalker a nightmarish fully terrestrial
descendant of the humble bat dixon
himself has stated the final chapters of
wells's the time machine were his
primary influence in creating after man
and the book can be considered a rebirth
of the genre the volume enjoyed
widespread success across the globe and
was even made into a stop-motion
animated adaptation in japan although
the project was never translated
following up on after man's success
dixon would create the new dinosaurs a
book that explored a hypothetical
alternate earth where the cretaceous
paleogene extinction event never
occurred
leading non-avian dinosaurs to evolve
into the present day the new dinosaurs
is one of the first entries in the
alternate timeline sub-genre of
speculative evolution
yet things became more complicated with
dixon's third book the bizarre man after
man which explores the evolution of
future humans various higher-ups altered
the book heavily during development and
dixon himself was reluctant to be
involved in the final version of the
project due to its lack of scientific
detail it did give us this famous image
which has been turned into a meme but
following the book's publication no
projects like it were released for some
time
in the early 90s a different kind of
speculative work would arrive on the
scene in the form of expedition created
by artist and writer wayne barlow
expeditions surveyed the alien ecosystem
of the fictional planet darwin 4 with
the same level of detail that dixon used
when exploring future timelines
the creatures of darwin 4 were designed
to be truly alien with barlow having
grown dissatisfied with the common
science fiction trope of alien life
being similar to life on earth
at the time of the book's publication
the kinds of aliens you'd see on tv were
mainly actors with things glued to their
foreheads yet the organisms of darwin 4
felt authentically like they'd emerge
from a different evolutionary line with
none of them possessing eyes hair or
external ears in the most intelligent
aliens of darwin 4 the bizarre floating
eosapians break the trend of aliens with
human-like intelligence needing to
appear humanoid
following the success of expedition the
book was adapted in 2005 into a cgi tv
special for the discovery channel titled
alien planet barlow served as the design
consultant and one of the executive
producers of the adaptation
throughout the early 2000s
computer-generated television specials
became a surprising haven for
speculative works including charles
foley's dragons of fantasy made real
which explored the hypothetical
evolution of a lost order of dragons
joanna adams's the future is wild also
came out around this time which explores
future ecosystems in a nature
documentary format dougal dixon was
actually one of the scientists who
helped develop the project and assisted
in designing many of the life forms the
future is wild is a speculative project
that remains unparalleled in terms of
scale and ambition and there's never
really been anything like it produced
since
during the latter 2010s speculative
evolution had a significant if often
overlooked impact on popular culture
dixon's the new dinosaurs heavily
influenced the direction of peter
jackson's king kong
even james cameron's avatar which
remains one of if not the most
successful film of all time owes heavy
inspiration to art wayne barlow created
for the movie
at the same time that speculative
evolution was influencing mainstream
media there was also an explosion of
availability in online projects and
leading the charge for early internet
speculative works was one cm koziman
born in turkey the young artist and
writer released the book all tomorrows
onto the internet in 2006
a fascinating and disturbing narrative
exploring future human evolution both
through genetic engineering and natural
means the book is something to behold at
once both nihilistic and strangely
hopeful taking inspiration from works
like last and first men all tomorrows
steadily grew an online following around
the same time kozaman also released
updates for a story called snyad a world
building project exploring the biology
of aliens on a fictional exoplanet
influenced by works like barlow's
expedition the sheer number of invented
creatures and lineages makes nyad one of
the most biologically diverse fictional
worlds a few years later kozaman would
release all yesterdays with artist john
conaway and paleontologist darin naish a
book that speculated on how dinosaurs
might have looked and behaved this
speculation actually helped inspire
projects like prehistoric planet the
book also contained a section titled all
todays which explored how aliens might
reconstruct earth animals based on the
fossil record with no knowledge of their
biology
like species filling niches of a new
environment speculative evolution would
become a bigger and more complicated
genre than ever thanks to online
possibilities the early works of artist
alex reese also hit the internet around
this time showcasing stunning depictions
of alien life in particular alex reese
would explore the development of an
intelligent hexapod species called the
buren creating one of the most
fascinating unbelievable alien cultures
across fiction leading up to the modern
day speculative evolution became more
accessible than ever before with a
growing community of people inspired by
the genre able to connect over vast
distances and today speculative
evolution is in the middle of a kind of
renaissance creators like christian
klein are now self-publishing entire
speculative books like the teeming
universe dylan beta helped kick-start a
new sub-genre with serena which has
popularized the idea of a seed world a
concept that involves leaving a few
species on an empty planet and following
their evolutionary path artist roxy
valdez has continued the tradition of
alternate timeline speculative evolution
with their frog centric amphitera
project the sheer number of speculative
projects being developed online right
now is amazing and the future of the
genre is looking bright
the history of speculative evolution is
a long and interesting road i couldn't
cover everything especially since
exactly what can be defined as
speculative evolution is somewhat
nebulous but i hope this offered a
helpful overview of the major milestones
and speaking of milestones this video is
releasing on the week of my channel's
one year anniversary whether you're a
long time fan or a first time viewer it
means so much that you've stopped by and
helped make this channel possible i've
explored many of the projects mentioned
here in greater detail and i have lots
of exciting things planned for the
future
and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
foreign